sixty thousand tons
of toxic waste
this whole area is extremely hazardous
and it's been sitting here bubbling away
for decades
this is an acid tar lagoon a swamp
made up of unmanaged dumped mess from
oil refineries near chester
just over here we'll find the acid tar
lagoon local councilor matt bryan
contacted us
to highlight these pernicious pits and
their blight
on his constituency it's a toxic waste
dump it's absolutely vile to be around
here
there's nothing living in there anything
that's close to
being alive is covered in oil and tar
and it's just a
generally disgusting place to be and as
you can see
it's bubbling the smell is awful um
and there's oil leaching out into the
ground around us
in the late 1970s dumping this kind of
industrial waste
was outlawed but before that disused
quarries were being filled up
with thousands of tons of poisonous
gunge and they're still here today
the environment agency claimed that the
clay bund holds it all in and as you've
seen
on the outskirts of the site even as far
as 100 meters away
we've got deep pools of tyre
which isn't good for the environment
whichever way you look at it this is the
legacy of bad decision making from the
1960s
and we've got a responsibility to sort
it out
this site is far from unique it's just
one part
of britain's dirty secret according to
the environment agency there are only
two
acetal lagoons in this country where our
investigation found
councils across the uk have officially
identified 34
and records show only a handful of them
are marked as hazardous but we can
reveal
there are many harmful toxic pits like
this
that have not been recorded and they
could be at least 150
across the country many of the sites
we've identified are in the north of
england
one in blackpool four in the amber
valley district of derbyshire alone
and another 18 recorded across northern
ireland
stopping the dumping only paused the
problem
the toxic waste already discarded hasn't
been cleaned up
in the 1980s a lagoon in wales was so
flammable
it burned for days when it was
accidentally set on fire
many properties of these pits are
similar we took samples
to see how dangerous they really are
hi nz if you pop that on we can go into
the lab
dr will meredith is an environmental
scientist at the university of
nottingham
he specializes in petrochemicals i've
added a small amount of the tar
into this vial and added a bit of water
and i'm now just going to test it with
this indicator paper
uh this is litmus which will indicate
the ph and as you can see
it goes to a bright red color indicating
a gauge of one to two
so this is a highly acidic material how
dangerous
is this acid i mean it's nasty it's
um it's going to be highly corrosive
it's not the sort of material that you
want to be exposed to
to get on your skin or on your clothes
the science shows
the impacts of acid lagoons have been
devastating
and they remain dangerous it's obviously
very damaging
locally from an environmental
perspective certainly from a wildlife
it's so acidic that things cannot grow
on it
without assistance and also if people
come into touch with it
into contact with it you know you can
get burns you can get corrosion
you can get damage it's our
responsibility as a community i think
to uh to to protect each other from
these
uh legacy sites of poorer environmental
standards in the past
oh look at that
it absolutely stinks and that's just
pure oil for years acitar lagoons have
been a hazard to our natural environment
controlled waters and in some instances
human health
particularly with people living nearby
i had no idea that it was here you don't
know much about them i feel like that is
a tad bit of a worry that you're not
told about them you're not made aware of
it so it's almost like it's trying to be
hidden in a way it's not made publicized
and the fact that there are so many
across the country
you know you would obviously prefer for
them to be treated so it makes it better
for the environment and you know local
wildlife
i mean i've been here for four years now
and i'm not don't know much
too much about it uh obviously i've got
kids so
the environment for the health of the
kids it's obviously not great being
there
it's literally a few hundred yards down
the road so
um it's not great for anyone that lives
in this area at all
having poisoned the environment for
decades cleaning them up now will cost
tens of millions of pounds some of the
sites are so
toxic there are no facilities in europe
large enough
to decontaminate them many of the
companies who once owned the land and
dumped the waste
are long gone today no one is taking
responsibility
the environment agency told us the
identification of these sites
sits with local authorities however when
asked we will work collaboratively to
inspect the land to ensure risks to the
environment are understood
and the area remains safe we've also
published technical guidance on waste
acid tars
to ensure these sites can be managed in
a way which limits
impact on the environment and
surrounding areas
[Music]
this is what is cleaning up the mess
we're now getting
the roots into the ground and into the
tower
for many years dr harvey wood has been
investigating
acid lagoons at this known site in derby
he's worked to try and make it safe but
is concerned
the national issue is too big the
environmental health departments across
the country
would rather not recognize these
because they do not know
how to go about the cleanup because they
see it as an open-ended
liability cost-wise and
no local authority is going to have that
kind of facility
to enable the cleanup and
no one who may own the land would like
to have that liability either
but dr wood has a solution and one that
works
this area used to be an acetal lagoon
but a sustainable
and very natural process means the toxic
waste
is no more we wanted to plant willows on
the
site because we know willows like acid
conditions
we covered the tar with a layer of
spent mushroom compost we then planted
the willows
and they've rooted into the tar down to
18 inches to two feet of the tar
in a lot of the areas and that is now no
longer acid
dr wood now hopes this process can be
used across the country
at other hazardous lagoons a cheaper
more eco-friendly fix
to these dangerous dormant sites
[Music]
acids are lagoons may have been around
for more than half a century
but still so little is known and being
done
about our irresponsibilities of the past
and for a nation
that is committed to be a world leader
on climate change
accepting this responsibility and
clearing up the mess of historical
actions
will no doubt help that cause